Let's say I have this
bizarre-looking function.
It's just some
arbitrary function.
And we'll call that f of x.
So this function right
there is f of x.
And what we're going to do in
this video is, it's not an
experiment, but we're going to
play around a little bit, and
we're going to try to
approximate this function
using a polynomial with
some coefficients.
And this polynomial we're going
to do, we're going to keep
adding terms to the polynomial,
so that we can better and
better approximate
this function.
And that's actually
called a power series.
And we'll do more about that
later, but we're going to
specifically try, in this case,
to approximate the function
around x is equal to 0.
So around this point.
So the easiest way to
approximate it is to say, well,
the simplest polynomial is
just a constant, right?
Let's say this is my
polynomial, let me call
my polynomial p of x.
The simplest polynomial is just
a constant, and it would just
be a horizontal line someplace.
So if I just wanted this one
term polynomial, what would be
my best approximation for this
function, at least
at this point?
Well, I could just set p
of x is equal to f of 0.
And in that case, p of x would
just look like a horizontal
line going through f of 0.
It would just look like that.
I'm going to erase that now,
just so I don't dirty up
this picture too much.
But that's, you could say,
a very rough approximation
of f of x, right?
So that's a start.
Well, what would be one way
to approximate it even more?
Well, what if not only does p
of x equal f of 0 at x is equal
to 0, so that horizontal line
we did, we got p of 0 is equal
to f of 0, so we knew that at x
equals 0, at least that
horizontal line is the same
value of f of x, that's a
very rough approximation.
But what if we set it up so
that the derivative of p of 0
is equal to the derivative
of the function at 0?
All of a sudden, this could be
a little bit more interesting.
So how could we set
it up like that?
Well, what if we set p of x,
and I'm doing it very general,
and we're going to do specific
examples, and actually, the
first example we're going to do
is probably the coolest one.
So what if p of x is equal to,
well, the constant term is f of
0, and then it's plus the
derivative of this function, so
the slope of this function at
that point, f prime
of 0 times x.
Let's say I'm defining,
so this is a polynomial.
I just added a first
degree term here.
I had a constant, and now I'm
adding a first degree term.
And let me confirm that this
will have the same derivative.
So let's see.
First of all, let's confirm
that p of 0 is equal to f of 0.
Well, p of 0 is equal to f of
0 plus f prime of 0 times 0.
Well, this last term just
goes to, is nothing, right?
Times 0.
So that checks out.
At x is equal to 0,
the two functions are
equal to each other.
Now let me confirm that their
derivative, their first
derivatives are the same.
So what's the first
derivative of p?
p prime of x is equal to,
well, the derivative of a
constant term is 0, right?
Plus, and what's the derivative
of a next term, of a
first degree term?
Well, it's just f prime of 0.
So this checks out.
My new polynomial that I've
defined right here is equal to
the function f at x is equal to
0, and its derivative is equal
to the function f at
x is equal to 0.
So what would it look like?
Well, it would intersect, at
x is equal to 0, the two
functions would overlap.
And also, they would have the
same slope at that point.
So whatever f of x is
doing, that function's
going to be doing.
So it's going to look something
like, I'm going to try my best
to, it's going to look
something like that.
And so that is a better
approximation, if we had to use
a line, that's as good as any,
especially around 0,
of what f of x is.
f of x might have been some
really crazy weirdo function,
but we were able to approximate
it reasonably well with this
very simple linear equation.
Well, that's all good, but
let's approximate it with a
quadratic equation, with adding
another x squared term.
And we're going to do that way,
but we're going to say, well,
we said, when at x is equal
to 0, the functions
equal each other.
That's what we did here.
Then we said, the derivatives
equal each other, and
so we added this term.
And now I'm going to say, what
happens when their second
derivatives equal each other?
So what has to happen for
their second derivatives
to equal each other?
Well, let's try out this,
and I think you'll start
to see the intuition here.
Let me define my new p of x,
so let me add another term.
p of x, the first terms
are going to be the same.
They're going to be f of 0.
Remember, this is just
a constant term.
Plus f prime of 0, the
first derivative at 0,
the slope at 0 times x.
Plus f prime prime, the second
derivative of the function at
0, times x squared over 2.
Now you're probably saying,
why are you multiplying
it by 1/2 here?
And you'll see, and maybe
you'll even realize it, when
you take a second derivative,
what happens, right?
You multiply the expression by
the exponents so you can have a
2 come down, it's going to
cancel out with the 1/2.
And that's why I
put the 1/2 there.
So that when I take the
derivative, that 2 and the 1/2
cancel out, and I'm just left
with the second derivative
of the original function.
So let me confirm that.
So p of 0 is equal to f of 0
plus, well when x is equal to
0, that's 0, this term is 0,
and when x is equal to 0,
that term is 0, right?
So that checks out.
What's the first
derivative of p?
The first derivative of p is
going to be, up here, this
was the first derivative
of p at 0, right?
So what's the first
derivative of p?
Well, the constant term becomes
0, plus-- oh, actually, no,
this was actually of x, sorry.
I shouldn't go back on my work,
I know it best when I'm doing
it the first time around.
Anyway.
The first derivative of p of x,
this is my current p of x, this
constant term, derivative of 0.
This x term, the derivative
is f prime of 0.
And then, what's the
derivative of this term?
Well, we take the exponent,
multiply it by the expression.
We have 2 times 1/2,
that cancels out.
So we're just left with
f prime prime of 0 x.
Right?
You take the exponent, multiply
by the whole thing, and then
decrement the exponent by 1.
So what is p prime of 0?
What is the derivative at 0?
Well, it equals,
this is nothing.
It equals f prime of 0
plus, and, well, this
term's going to be 0.
So that checks out.
And so what's the
third derivative?
Let me clean up some of
the stuff on the top.
Since this is our current f
of x anyway, I can clean
up all of this stuff.
Let me clean up all of this.
So what is the third derivative
of this p that I defined here?
This is our current p.
Well, the third derivative is
going to be, so p prime prime
prime of x, we could have also
written p3 of x, is equal
to the derivative of this.
Oh, sorry, we're not on
the third, we're only on
the second derivative.
p, and I'll write prime prime,
I was going to write a 2 there.
p prime prime of x.
That equals what?
That's the derivative of this.
So there was a 0 here,
that goes to nothing.
This is now a constant term,
that becomes nothing.
And then we take the
derivative of this term.
Well, we just, it's
a constant times x.
Remember, this might look like
a function or some variable.
It's just a constant.
Because we evaluated this
curvy function, it's
second derivative 0, so we
just got a number here.
So this derivative is
just this number.
So it equals f
prime prime of 0.
And so our current p of x has
the same value when x is equal
to 0 as f of x, it has the same
first derivative at xis equal
to zero as f of x, it has
the same second derivative.
And I don't, this is getting
beyond my visualization
ability, especially for an
arbitrary function like this,
but I could guess that maybe
it looks something like this.
I don't know.
Maybe it looks, maybe our new
function will curve, and it'll
approximate it a little
bit better, and then maybe
it'll come down like that.
I don't know.
I'm just guessing.
But around x is equal to 0,
it's going to be a better
approximation of f of x.
Well, we could just keep doing
this, and actually, we will
keep doing this, and you know,
just saying, well, the zeroth
derivative, or at the value, is
the same the first derivative
is the same at 0, the second
derivative is the same at 0,
we'll say the third derivative,
the fourth derivative, and
we'll keep doing that.
And I only have 20 seconds left
in this video, so we will
continue that in
the next video.